do you have any opinions on uh Elon Musk
what he's doing with Twitter
I think that uh Twitter's coming back to
life I think it's I think Twitter had
too many training wheels on it you know
too much governance on it
if you look at any economy I mean any
economy at all I mean the recipe for
crippling the economy is too many
well-intentioned bureaucrats regulating
and everything telling you what you can
and you can't do Ronald Reagan you know
fixed the U.S economy or if Margaret
Thatcher the intelligent thing they do
is when they deregulate get out of the
way and stop second guessing the people
I think on Twitter I mean they they act
so many accounts right when you ask
people that disagree with the current
thing and you obliterate their accounts
it's very chilling
and so uh Elon has I I do believe that
his motivation is give free speech to
the world I think it's a very
complicated thing to do when there are
so many laws about what's acceptable
speech and what isn't
but um I think that uh that uh Twitter
was kind of stuck in a malaise and uh
they were they were basically they're
they're a digital Monopoly on public
speech and they were siphoning off all
of their energy simply to regulate
the speech and when you step back and
say what if we just let people talk and
we and we put our energy into improving
the product
like make the product better I mean
there's no reason why you can't provide
like give 100 million people the ability
to get verified why didn't they do that
it was a it was a very they had a very
Socialist Communist idea which is 300
000 blue checks and no amount of money
or effort on your part will get you
verified
so 300 million proletariat proletarians
and 300 000 Elite and even if you wanted
to write me a ten thousand dollar check
to verify you I'm not taking it so it
was very stuck and uh well some
employees took some checks and they gave
verification behind closed doors what I
tell them same thing with insta yeah and
the same thing happens in communist
regimes where you have rationing it's
invariably of a black market form so I
think that Elon is he's making moves to
improve the process improve the
functionality open up free speech there
should be debate people should not live
in fear of what they say you say the
wrong thing you express the wrong
opinion and your account gets locked and
you get Shadow banned and I think that
that undermined the use of the platform
and uh and so I you know I'm in favor of
where they're headed I I think it's good
for the world I think it's auspicious
it's going to be a bumpy ride ride like
most most of the time when with elon's
business they're all bumpy rides Tesla
was a bumpy ride but he likes that but
you know when you step back and you're
like Tesla's a bumpy ride but it looks
like we're getting to the point where
cars will drive themselves and you start
to think well maybe when we get to the
end of the ride it'll be a good thing so
what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people were in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hats especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks spread toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]